um Natalie are you doing the YouTube
it started okay right attendance is
there's a sheet going round for you to
sign
uh there's only one item to consider
which is the reconsideration of a review
of an existing premising premises
license the Astoria Bar and Grill
32 to 34 flixton Road urmston
um just by way of introductions I'm
councilor German I'm the chair of the
subcommittee with me I've got councilors
Thomas and Bot
and we have offices from licensing legal
and governance
now
as this is an appeal against the review
the appellant is the
it goes down as the applicant which is
Mr Shaw is that Mr Shaw sorry Mr Shaw
you're the licensee of the Astoria bar
and we have um PC Lloyd from greater
Manchester police who brought the review
oh yeah yeah yeah
right but you've you've taken over the
right the review okay
um so I'll now uh release uh just go
through the procedure for the meeting
um so first I will ask the licensing
officer to outline the application
then I will ask the applicant which is
Mr Shaw uh to address the subcommittee
and call the new Witnesses
the applicant and each of their
Witnesses May then be questioned by
members of the subcommittee offices
offices and any other party making
representation
uh the party represent making
representation
um well there would be no referred to as
the representer
and the representatives will be given an
opportunity to address the subcommittee
and call the new Witnesses uh in this
case it's the
uh the police
which is PC Lloyd
after this I'll request all all parties
involved to summarize
the representer
or representators PC Lloyd will be given
two minutes to summarize followed by the
applicant Mr Shaw who would also be
given two minutes
the subcommittee will then retire to
consider their decision and then I will
announce the determination the
application and the reasons for the
determination
and this will be confirmed in writing
within five days of the hearing
so is everybody clear about the
procedure can I not just slightly chair
because this is an unusual case because
this is a matter that was heard at the
magistrates Court in Manchester on the
31st of October when the district judge
heard from Mr Shaw uh that he had
reached agreement with the police about
various conditions and that the police
were not in attendance at that hearing
they were not required to be
uh and um as a result of what was said
the district judge directed at the
matter be remitted back to a licensing
subcommittee so the rules of appeal
still apply and those rules are that it
is for the appellant which uh the
magistrates court court was Mr Shaw to
satisfy the tribunal that considers his
appeal that the decision of the
subcommittee on on review on the
original review was wrong and in order
to do that the the decision makers have
to consider what the decision was
they have to consider any evidence that
they might hear and they have to decide
having taken into account the
application of the policy and everything
else that was heard uh whether that was
decision was wrong and felt to be uh
reversed it's right also to say that in
the magistrates Court there was
discussion as to whether this matter
should probably be an application to
vary the license because
um that is what is what is essentially
being sought in in this review and the
advantages to Mr Shaw in pursuing a
variation rather than appeal is that he
would not have to show that your
decision was wrong and I think I also
ought to highlight one other matter
uh chair and that is at 7 39 let's see
1739 this evening
so that was uh 51 minutes before this
hearing was due to convene uh an email
was uh received from Mr Shaw making
representations which you have
uh I don't know whether Mr Lloyd can
confirm whether that has been been
reviewed by Karen Packer who was the
original
um original applicant in these matters
and who maybe have been taken by
surprise boat
thank you thank you thank you Mr Ferry
um Miss Boyle do you want to outline the
application Mickey
um as a subcommittee may recall on the
third of February 2022 it considered an
application from greater Manchester
police requesting a review of the
premises license in respect the premises
known as Astoria Bar and Grill
32-34 flixton road urmston on the
grounds of prevention of crime and
disorder and ensuring Public Safety
the subcommittee decided to attach a
number of additional conditions to the
license to take effect after the period
in which an appeal could be made
the premises license holder sure Leisure
holding limited did submit an appeal
against the decision which was
subsequently considered by Manchester
magistrates court on the 31st of October
2022 at the hearing the premises license
solder informed the court that the
police had agreed that conditions the
conditions opposed by the subcommittee
might be varied by way of a variation
applications to the licensing Authority
premises lies and solar but not at that
stage made an application to the
licensing Authority and so asked the
court to agree to vary the conditions
stating that an agreement had been
reached with greater Manchester police
the court did not consider this in such
circumstances it was empowered to vary
those conditions
as the court could not be satisfied that
the decision was wrong and there was no
representative of Greater Manchester
police present to confirm the nature or
extent of any variation
in such circumstances the court emitted
the matter back to the licensing
subcommittee but it gave no specific
direction as to how the matter should be
decided
in such circumstances the licensing
subcommittee must rehear the matter and
consider any representations that may be
made by greater Manchester police and
the premises license holder
it must then make such a determinant
determination as it considers necessary
that those are the the options it had at
the time of the original hearing
either to promote to promote the
licensing objectives namely to modify
the conditions of the license to exclude
all accessible activity from the scope
of the license
to remove the designated premises
supervisor to suspend the license for
appearing or exceeding three months or
to revoke the license
thank you chat so I'll have it to say at
the start thank you Mr Boyle does
anybody have any questions for the
licensing officer
I mean we we've all got the bundle of
evidence from the original hearing
um or 100 and so pages of it we've all
seen the 90-minute DVD in evidence for
the original
preview so we don't really need to to to
revisit that as such we are all aware of
it so in that case I'll ask Mr Shaw
would you like to present
his case for the appeal and and also why
we should be hearing it tonight rather
than the variation application yeah
I took advice at the time
[Music]
as opposed to
submit a better Edition
um
obviously
privilege
I took that on face value I appreciate
members of the committed I had to come
back perhaps
you maybe agreed by that but I do
apologize it's not my Inception I'm a
sort of I just took advice on that but
that's why
[Music]
sorry could you put your mic there's a
button the button front me sorry it's
because you've been working that's it
you're right
[Music]
but
so that's that matter
um secondly Mr Parry makes reference uh
as he did in court that
in order to
overturn or compromise the original
decision we have to prove I have to
prove rather that the decision was in
fact wrong
if if it is a case of right and wrong
then obviously I'm going I am going to
argue that that the decisions made were
wrong
as they were too severe for what was
submitted
um you've seen my submissions this
evening or you will have them in front
of you now
and I hope that you can see why
why I'm looking for compromise on some
of the matters uh it's not just
for from a business and Commercial Point
of View
it's also the fact that we we've been
operating on under the terms of our old
license which was was initially up for
review we've been operating on that
since the appeal was submitted
and
I think it's fair to say and I I hope
that GMP and its Representatives would
agree with this that
how we operate now is is very different
to how we operated when we first opened
it was very difficult at the time it was
a new Venture it was which I discussed
before and it was very difficult
now knowing what we know and how we work
we do not feel
that the severe restrictions that were
put on conditions at the time
that they are they are necessary
and sadly in the current climate and I
know this isn't something that you may
or may not consider but in the current
climate those conditions will result in
closure of the venue and job losses
which is obviously something I would
much rather avoid
would you like me to discuss the
conditions that I'm
appealing so the first one would be
removal of the age limit of the under-20
ones so you you decided that we couldn't
permit people to enter we're under 21 uh
before between 18 and 21. that is
unnecessary
um the evidence bundle that PC Packer
originally submitted
um I don't actually think she submitted
the age of any anybody involved in
anything however
the profile of anybody who ever caused
any trouble in 2019-2020
did not fall into this category
the second condition would be the
removal of no admittance after quarter
to 11.
um
this this wasn't discussed at the time I
thought we actually thought that this
went
PC Packer wanted to bring the terminal
hour to 12 o'clock and the way we read
her submissions were that
it was 12 o'clock
last at 12 o'clock closure and quarter
to 11 last entry
we spoke about the terminal hour that
was decided that he could stay where it
was at 1am
and assume this went hand in hand this
this is very damaging the quarters to
11. we do when the pubs close at 11 we
do catch that last couple of hours trade
it is a busy period for us again it
would result in
delaying off of stuff
the third condition that we would like
to appeal would be the the security
numbers PC Packer asked for five
sorry five on a Friday five on a
Saturday three on a Sunday
we the decision on the on the appeal
sorry the decision on the review
was four-door staff Saturday
three's door staff Sunday
we've been up the odd license
allows for two-door staff Friday
Saturday none on a Sunday
we've been working with two door staff
and two at eight o'clock and one at nine
o'clock Friday Saturday and very minimal
use of police resources whilst working
with those numbers we've never operated
with security staff on a Sunday
um it's a very quiet day there's not a
lot of business going on it's a quiet
street in in urmston at that time there
really is no need for security staff on
a Sunday evening save for prior to a
bank holiday or special occasion I I
even included
our average tokens on a Sunday and what
the cost of security would be it again I
understand you're not here to look at
how my business operates from a
commercial sense I'm just trying to
explain that it it does show the
footfall and that the average we would
actually be paying people to supervise
next to nobody
and the lastly the use of
polycarbonates polycarbonates
we
since the review and we did take about
everything what was discussed we have
aim to Target a different clientele one
of which is through our drinks offering
and we want to serve much more upmarket
drinks cocktails we have better trained
staff mixologists who can make a nice
well presented cocktail
it's very difficult for us to do that in
a plastic glass it does alter the
Aesthetics of the players and I think it
actually gives off the wrong impression
I understand that on the original
evidence served by PC Packer that there
was an incident of somebody being over a
glass being used as a weapon on somebody
however
that was once and don't get me wrong
once he's in you know I'm not I'm not
disputing that I'm not discounting it
but nothing's ever happened since
I believe the bit more there'll be
venues where this has happened far more
than mine and this this hasn't been this
condition hasn't been imposed on them I
I really would ask the committee
consider that we we are allowed to keep
glass vessels
please
that's my submissions and I hope you can
uh
think about those please
since the um license uh review which if
any of the conditions that were imposed
have you observed
I think there was 30 odd of them yeah so
the big
30 30 31 we've been we've been paused
um we've also
things that may not be a condition we
have uh implemented anyway such as we
have put on extra security staff
more so than the actual license that
we're operating on we have increased the
dress code
um we do now operate with a one
strikeout policy anybody who attends the
premises any that breaches any roles any
any of the license objectives it is
depending on what they've done a three
six or in three month six month or an
indefinite ban
so in terms of security stuff you say
you've increased your provision of
security stuff yes how many security
staff do you have on on
um
uh the individual days on Fridays
Saturdays and Sundays three on a Friday
three on a Saturday we don't have any on
a Sunday
unless it was to fall before a bank
holiday and in terms of polycarbonate
glasses have you purchased any we did
purchase them after the review
um
that many of them end up either in the
bin or stolen which is sad
um we have been using our old glass
natural Glass glasses
[Music]
and
you said
um that you you decided to see the
appeal through rather than applying for
a variation of your license yes
um you understand
um as uh Mrs Boyle told the committee
that the magistrate the district judge
said he could not be dissatisfied that
the decision was wrong and therefore
could not uh agree to vary the decision
which was one of the things he could
have done on appeal what do you think
has changed with your submissions now to
that that existed before the magistrates
court on the 31st of October
the district judge could not be
satisfied that the decision that the
subcommittee made was wrong he he said
that when he remitted the case back here
you you need to I I would argue Mr Perry
that the district judge said he wasn't
best placed to hear the appeal I think
that's what he's had I don't think he
said it was right or wrong
well he said in those circumstances he
could not be dissatisfied that the
decision was wrong I don't I don't
recall right well
what do you say what would you say to
this committee that would satisfy them
that the decision they made on the 31st
of October was wrong it was wrong
because they were the conditions Imports
were too severe
you understand of course that the
imposition of Licensing conditions is
not punitive it is to ensure that their
licensing objectives are upheld yeah and
I feel that in the in this case that was
wrong because the licensed objectives
have been met by looser conditions
I'm not not as restrictive it would be a
better better for us thank you chair I
have no further questions okay thank you
Mr Parry so Mr Shaw is saying it's two
so the conditions are too severe I think
what we're looking for is evidence
really yeah
we just you're just asking us really to
take take your word for it
and I think with the variation then or
you can produce your evidence which can
be shared with all parties and then
everybody can make a considered decision
you know there could be visits to your
premises by the by the police or the
licensing officers to view and and see
that you've actually
put these measures into practice
so I think that's what we're looking for
is evidence so I think we strongly
leaning towards variation application
rather than dealing with it on appeal
which is which is
um very limited but can I ask you the
much was made about the policies that
that you that should have been
you should have been given to the
licensing authority of those policies
now being yeah there was shared a day or
two after the uh initial review
exactly you've got you've got it's the
licensing Authority got there I believe
they went to a PC packer
they've not been since the lasting
Authority so they may have been sent to
the licensing yeah
CCTV drugs search policies
I believe this was by myself and Karen
had a slight overlap I do believe that
currency these back in January or
February sometime and folded them on to
assuming that the team inbox but that is
my understanding is as of now
I think it was it was two or three days
after the after the event yeah
so you're saying you've lodged them with
GMP the distance
yeah should happen yeah that can that
can that can be pursued yeah what in
your view since the hearing in February
the original review what what has
improved at your premises what visible
signs would we see has there been any
incidents since then I think to my to my
knowledge I think there's been one
possibly two call outs to the police
in eight eight months I think it was I
think about around eight months I'm sure
uh PC like can can say otherwise or
agree that
um but what's improved it's just it's
just
what don't you think is from that
hearing that was oh we're appealing and
not taking into consideration anything
that was said or anything that was
presented because we 100 did
as such we
went through our policies which we
shared with yourselves
we
change the security staff we changed the
way we operate we changed some staff
members we changed the DPS it was the
DPS at the time of when you when the
evidence was submitted the DPS is no
longer part of the business it's a new
DPS
it's just ran a lot better it's ran a
lot more stricter but also you know
people can still come and enjoy
themselves and that that's what we want
that's we want to find that middle
ground and I believe we have at the
moment
yeah I mean we need to see the evidence
clearly I mean it's I mean we hope
you're correct and then yeah he's saying
is absolutely correct so I'll just ask
my colleagues if you have any questions
a bit confusing it kind of uh I took
over the current at the start of this
year's licensing officer but Karen
maintained this review because it was so
close to the end or at least it was
believed it was very close to the end at
the time
um
in relation to a couple of bits that I
will just mention then
um
you talk about the address called
variation and talk about changes of DPS
and things like that
you mentioned crimes and incidents there
are still call outs to Astoria
um I haven't presented a document to the
extent that PC Packer did because that
was for the review to number them and go
through them there are still some
call-outs and I couldn't say if they
were more or less
um that we've been instructed to do so
and we have a specific question for me
about something that will mentioned
which actually do you have any questions
for Mr Shaw
particularly so you mentioned dress code
yeah
there was obviously a recommendation
that the committee instructed about uh
what is and caps you mentioned about
adding something yourself what's that
we
we just no combats no no tactical where
you know you know what I mean by the
Tactical where don't you so no combats
no tactical where uh hoodies and hats
hoodies are allowed obviously hold down
hats off
okay yeah just a strict address card you
mentioned at the very start when you put
forward gmp's representational outdoor
staff
Karen actually asked for six
yeah right Karen asked for six on the
Friday the Saturday and Sunday obviously
there was some negotiation at the time
of the hearing and that was reduced down
to your recommendation which was five
Friday and Saturday staggered start
times and three on a Sunday
and you've been operating did you
use those numbers for this after hearing
for any period of time yes we did yeah
okay
I can see where my difficulty is about
comparing your crime numbers and
incidents at the venue where for some
period of time since the panel
you have been using these conditions I
think it was for two or three weeks
until we started
it's almost a success of reduced calls
could be down to the fact that the
decisions that the panel made and
instructed have worked and then the risk
is to
risk is that things go back I understand
the only concern
um a DPS change obviously you've
mentioned one of the conditions was that
the DPS was to be removed
I know you you struck to the DPS who
I've worked with over the last six
months or so what's your current
situation like because I know I've had
an email from the council said it in a
DTS change again is that right GPS in
place yeah there's a DPS in place right
yeah a new one yes right
does that mean sorry has that been
reflected on the license is that yeah
I've submitted it to Katie Armstrong
Monday or Tuesday this week
right so it will be if not I've got any
more confirming this that's fine yeah
that's okay
thank you uh can I ask how many uh how
many draw stuff where body comes
we've got two body cams at the moment
yeah because again at the time two of
the doorstep was supposed to our body
comes and the manager yes that was a
condition that was a condition yeah yeah
so you've no idea to that condition at
the moment but we do have body cameras
yeah two yeah or three two and then the
manager does wear one yeah so you have
got three yeah okay thank you
um
the no readmittance uh at courtroom so
from quarter 11 onwards
um what what pubs in urmston
close at 11 o'clock
quite quite a lot we get quite a lot of
our business comes between 11 and and
one I would say an hour but the pubs
don't particularly close they just
perhaps they just filter out and
possibly yeah I think I think there are
several that 11 is the closure how often
do you carry out search and ID checks
on anybody who doesn't look 25 we can
use the challenge 25. and Drug checks on
anybody entering who's carrying a bag or
a yeah
in front of CCTV yeah we've got a camera
on the doorway so yeah it's always
conducted I'm looking at conditions yeah
and I'm looking at where from from what
we've received tonight
uh
could be deemed as
contrary to the conditions that we set
right okay
um
foreign
polycarbonate glasses
no aesthetic
difference really
between a good college class
and a normal glass class
in fact a polycarbonate glass will last
longer in your glass washer than any
class class and there are now a big
swathe of
Brewers breweries that are using logoed
polycarbonate glasses with
um a little fizzy bits at the bottom
and they're also extremely classy
looking wine glasses champagne flutes uh
cocktail glasses that you can use
as a point the point is
that again a condition was given that
polycarbonate because of the glassware
going outside
going to the front of the property
outside when you shouldn't have been and
breaking on the floor it wasn't about
just being used to the weapon it's about
the danger it causes to Street users
because narrow pavement where you are
and then other Road users well we we
don't permit glasses of any kind to be
taken outside
after nine o'clock anyway and of course
at nine o'clock our furniture is bright
inside so
the the reason there shouldn't be any
classes outside at that time okay
for me at the moment thank you yeah
I think there's a point made
um
in the report regarding
uh
that the officers confirmed there was no
DPS present during
uh or supervisor present during one or
two of the incidences has that been the
case in in recent times you know the
last few incidents that have happened
I couldn't say something that would be
chatter in place of attended stuff
because the current license that you
recommended where DPS must be on site
found on Saturdays hasn't had to be in
place
um
I got accurate answer that question that
would hopefully be something that will
convince here to you
[Music]
we've had a DPS on shift on those those
guys whereas where where the it was
decided that we needed them
right so those last two incidents you
indicated over the last six there was
some DPS was on site yeah
I can volunteer that that's done a
couple of vlps in that time there has
been a DPS on site at those times but if
you weren't asking about incidents I
couldn't tell you that accurately okay
so Mr shore of the conditions that we
attached to the license in February how
many of them would you say
you were adhering to or if it's easy how
many aren't you and which ones aren't
you adhering to
four four yes just these four just the
four yeah everything else is absolutely
no no contest
contention that's the right word sorry
okay
anybody else have any more questions for
Mr Show
Mr Lloyd would you like to add anything
in terms of your
submission
first to say thank you chair and
councils for arranging to meet tonight
I've obviously unusually this is not my
initial variation that was brought about
by GMP initially a PC Packer obviously
she presented evidence to you and a long
list of suggestions of possible
conditions and that decision was made by
yourselves
um I've obviously worked with the bar in
the meantime since then
um
you've obviously made your decision at
the time to allow the premise to stick
to license objectives
um
there's a couple on there that obviously
are concerning as to the implications of
removing so many combinations with
others and that's that's the only
concern going forward
so it's correct you weren't out there
you weren't at the appeal here I wasn't
impulse at the time but you'd had a
conversation with Mr Shaw which he
concluded that you may be amenable at
some point so I think you put in your
email yes that's correct so after this
had gone on for a while and was where an
objection was being submitted
um it was said I would approach them and
find out what potentially their
variation would be or what their
objection was going to include
um saw that information back to
licensing partners and then we'll which
presented an option to submit a
variation
um left it with them to see legal advice
and to finalize what they're going to do
and then a few weeks later
um had a meeting up something else and
they decided that um informed that they
wouldn't be going down the option and
the reason was as to why
do you think they think there's mileage
and going down the variation option in
fact there might be some movement if you
like on the conditions
if it's looked at in a different way
we had gone through what he wanted to
put on the variation
um
we'd agreed what he would consider
putting on it but then obviously he was
saying Go away and farm lines up with
legal advice to them submit it for us to
actually consider but that process
wasn't formalized or gone through that
would have been I think I mentioned the
date roughly I think it was end of June
early July I think it was
uh it's not been discussed
yeah because I think you said yourself
and and uh Karen Parker
um said that there may be in the future
some possibility and movement on the age
policy that's going to re-admittance
policy that's correct words are sure
about the doorstep
I think if I'm being honest the the age
and the admittance
the ones that I said and Karen
record of an objection to I would not
object to I should say more accurately
um make sure we're taking away too much
at once
to allow more people in with a reduced
reduction in what you ask them to have
security wise something I'd obviously
put back to the parents to consider
do you have a view on the um
polycarbonate condition that's the days
times the polycarbonate condition has
not been mentioned to me prior to
walking here tonight so I'm not really
much time to consider it
um
I don't have a an opinion at the minute
no
okay thank you you have any questions
for PC Lloyd yeah
thank you Mr slide uh just not a
bicarbon it's in Manchester if you have
two incidents of uh a glass being used
as a weapon yeah they will force
polycarbonates onto
onto venues certainly within the
northern quarter under the parts of
spinning fields
um the police themselves do that unless
that has changed in the last
four years since I came out of that
sector I would suggestions they'll ask
in their team a large nighttime economy
and no for the football club that I
managed to deal with that we officer
polycarbonate rules for their match
statement fixtures but during match days
yeah no that's fine uh and also um
I'm a little bit concerned about the the
removal of the under 21s because
that opens up the door to people with
ideas are very difficult for licensees
across the borough to recognize and see
and and
police in a way that they want to I'm
sure I'm not suggesting for one moment
that any licensee in Trafford would like
to have 16 or 17 year old or younger
in their pubs um
but it does make it very very difficult
for them especially as there's no food
so Saturday Friday Saturday is that
correct we do serve food on an evening
we serve up until nine o'clock up until
nine o'clock that's all right sorry okay
so I'm a little bit concerned perhaps
after nine o'clock and of relaxing that
that
um remember with the no the admittance
again it
turned it from from my memory of the DVD
that we saw on the CCTV that we saw it
tended to cause quite a lot of uh
traffic going down
later on on flexton road which is a busy
road maybe quiet at uh quieter at uh 11
o'clock 12 o'clock at night but it is
still a main thought of that so I'm
concerned that that may may happen
um
with the security I'm just you know you
what are your thoughts on on that
because obviously
where whereby and I understand that the
figures that Mrs Jones put forward uh
does make it quite uh prohibitive but
we're coming through to what I'm sure Mr
Shore and every license he hopes is the
busiest Christmas we've ever had some
again I'd like your opinion on the on
the doorstuff numbers because of where
we're at yeah
thank you for those questions
I think
the original list of conditions and the
evidence that was submitted to you back
at the hearing at the time obviously my
colleague wouldn't have suggested the
people coming back in or the age group
if there wasn't
some kind of documented evidence to show
that younger people were part of the
problem be it inside or outside are part
of the instance generally as a whole
there was a quite a long list of
condition sent to you for your
consideration and obviously you've
selected those
um
I think the door staff
change of doorstep
with enough numbers could potentially
mitigate
to younger people coming in and the
readmiscence
but it is very much a choice of
either one of
one or the other in my opinion I I would
feel uncomfortable with
the change of door policy as far as the
Aging the admittance along with
a change to what GMP recommended
originally of your consideration as far
as done others
um yes there is a risk of it
please talk about managing that risk as
far as having the right people on to to
deal with incidents quickly and be able
to be on the door to a few people who
need refusing and enough staff to be on
to check ID properly using the right age
verification systems
um
throughout this of all these decisions
ultimately
um my ultimately this would just be
changing all of them at the same time
there is a possibility obviously a
staggered approach but that's again for
a committed to to consider on if you're
some guidance
thank you come to the boat do you have
any questions with PC Lord
Mr Shaw do you have any questions please
see Lloyd
yeah I'd just like to say them as as you
know uh PC line we have been operating
allowing under 20 ones in allowing a
readmittance after quarter to 11 with at
the same time with three door staff
now would you agree that there has been
a reduction in
use of police resources
since since you're
position as a licensing officer
I would
I would say I haven't even shot to two
are compiled evidence the same forensic
level that PC packet did for the purpose
of the review so I cannot stand here you
know one Testament and say there has
been a drop and here are the number of
drops
um
would I say that
has there been a change yes
but I've also got to be aware of the
fact that they have been operating under
a bit of a spotlight for the last 10
months
and that was obviously been reflected in
some of the practices they've done
but I'm also aware of the fact that your
decision was based on the evidence that
was put to you at the time and the
recommendations by the police and there
was obviously some evidence from finding
for you to reach those conditions and
now perhaps being console to say I feel
that those should be reduced based on my
fairly small window of involvement while
they're already under a bit of a
microscope of having this hearing and
review under underway
um personally I have had a good working
relationship with Will
we have a degree negotiated quite quite
a few things but I'm also very mindful
that we are responsible Authority and it
is each person's best interest to to get
on
um but I'm very aware the fact that
you've made your decision it's very
lengthy process you went through
um and you're experiencing these matters
um have been asked to check the figure
so I can't give an accurate
representation on that I would
definitely not say it has gone no worse
I can't say if it's the same or better
without being confident of that
I I actually I'm in a position to say
that and whilst of course I'm going to
say that what I'm saying to now is is
the truth that has been a has been a
sizable reduction I know myself I know I
have much sleep much better on an
evening now knowing that I'm not going
to get a call from John or anybody like
seeing on a Monday morning because
there's been police attendances
I know that if the Figures were to be
looked at that would 100 substantiate
what I am saying now
I I have to be very quite passionate
about this because that increased cost
will result in close with my venue
now I will maintain every licensing
objective
under what I've what I'm asking you to
to hear
but I just I cannot work under those
they are too too prohibitive
they it will it will force us to close
down
all right thank you for that do you have
any further questions of BC really
thank you
okay do you PC Lord you wish to
summarize before we adjourn to make a
decision on this
I think I kind of gave what I had in my
head as a summer kind of in responsible
question that has just had that
um I don't want to take any more of your
time after looking further on you to to
add to what I've already mentioned in my
responses okay thank you Mr Shaw would
you like to I did write a song I think
I'm pretty much echoing what I've
already said that you know we've made
progress since the initial review
um
whilst we may have been operating under
the terms of the old license we have
implemented increased policies of our
own such as
the dress code the we have increased the
door staff just not to the numbers that
were mentioned in the review
um
we're not lenient so the one strike in
your out policy and
um
a much uh
pclr just touched on now
which in fact I remember yourself
actually encouraged it a much better
working relationship and a much more
open dialogue between myself and well at
their new and GMP and I think that and
everything that I've just said Has
resulted in us operating in a much
better way I do think the objectives of
the initial review can be met with what
I have put across tonight
and obviously my own involvement with
the venue I'm I'm there every day pretty
much
yeah I I it's it's my livelihood I need
it to work I need to work with everybody
involved
I I just need to be able to
pay the bills
to
but I apologize that you had to come
back apology we didn't go through the
variation which in hindsight listen to
you perhaps that probably was the best
route to go down
like I said I took legal advice at the
time but I appreciate you coming out
this evening thank you maybe you'll get
another bite of the Cherry
another opportunity
it'd be nice to just get back to work
well thank you for that
um we'll adjourn the meeting while we
make a decision I think
um it'll be easier for yourselves to
sort of if you like take yourself
outside for a few minutes while we make
the decision rather than the panel and
we'll do legal officers of course if
that's okay
um when you're ready we'll uh if you
couldn't
take yourself outside we'll discuss the
the application